75 hectares de jardin classé monument
historique en 1973 le plus grand et le
jardin à la française créée entre 1897
et 1903 henry de breteuil s'adresse aux
duchesne un père et son fils paysagiste
français voici c'est le jardin à la
française construit vers 1900 un parc à
la française est fait pour être vu de
hauteur mais là on a la chance d'avoir
une terrasse qui vous permet même des
jardins de pouvoir le voir en plus haut
et c'est en allant près de la porte
centrale du château pousserait juste à
la bonne hauteur pour voir ce parc c'est
un jardin comme on les faisait au xviie
siècle certains traits réguliers dont
par exemple les allées correspondent à
l'extérieur ou en partie centrale du
château et il y a typiquement déduit des
ifs taille et c'est par exemple celui ci
un grand plan d'eau un plan d'eau qui
les jours de beau temps reflète le
château et ceux qui l'entourent
à ses côtés un cèdre donné par marie
antoinette à une des dames de breteuil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
passion de séverine de breteuil le
jardin des princes rené en 1991 le
jardin de fleurs et créer à la place de
l'ancien potager avec un esprit xviie
siècle avec tes pièces un peu fermé avec
des charmes par exemple qui permettent
de s'isoler
il ya des allées des plates-bandes avec
des fleurs qui sont certaines des
vivaces et d'autres qui sont changés
régulièrement des annuelles et
il a été réalisé par séverine de
breteuil avec un paysagiste ap les
pêcheurs qui s'inspirait de travail de
witte belge en floraison toute l'année
ce jardin possède des variétés
spécifiques pour chaque saison en ce
printemps les stars viennent de très
loin comme ses cerisiers japonais
ils seront bientôt remplacés par les
pivoines
[Musique]